foreign
[Music]
this is the Reuben report it's February
28 2023 and that's right everybody it is
the last day of February only 28 days in
February which means that today
sad to say is the last day of black
history month so I hope that you all got
your black history I know that if you
were to read any books about black
history here in the State of Florida you
would be accosted and arrested by Rhonda
Santos's thugs that drive around the
nondescript cars they're always taking
people out you know if you're walking
your dog talking about about black
history or if you're gay
how they know we don't know but they
grab you black bag on your head you're
never seen again so we lost a lot of
people so I just want to first off just
my condolences to anyone who you know
lost somebody during black history month
because of Rhonda status or the gay
thing and uh also you know for me it was
a wonderful I think out of all the black
history months this was the big one for
me out of all of them I mean every time
I turned on Hulu black programming
everywhere and I only watched if a white
person literally showed up in anything
that I was watching I immediately shut
it off and I would punch the dog didn't
want anything to do with it uh you know
if I put on Playstation tell me games by
black people I watch a lot of The
Jeffersons
um I was out there doing my thing and I
hope you did too so it was a wonderful
month for everybody very exciting time
to be alive and uh if you don't know
guys we have a post game show where we
do more of this sort of comedic genius
at
reubenreport.locals.com and I am really
looking forward to the show today on
this last day of black history month
because I'm going to make fun of people
regardless of their skin color actually
some of them are black but I'm not
making fun of them because they're black
some of them are white I'm not making
fun of them because they're white
although to some degree it has a little
something to do with their guiltness
over their whiteness but we'll get to
that but really today is just an
absolute destruction of the people who
give the machine everything it wants
this is a concept I've been saying over
and over again
this type of media person who
automatically swallows the line of the
machine and tells you immediately how
you should live and then in almost every
case because time because truth is a
Time release pill we find out that they
are wrong and they are mostly clownish
and buffoonish in their actions so we're
going to go through some late night
hosts who got everything wrong some
MSNBC people surprise surprise who got
everything wrong we've got Joy Reed
we've got Anna Navarro and then we've
got some good stuff going on in case you
did not know we'll get to more on this
later today is book release day for
governor Ron DeSantis uh his book uh the
courage to be free the courage to be
free yes the courage to be free is out
today and I interviewed him yesterday
we're going to put it up uh I believe at
1 15 p.m Eastern today it's just kind of
a mini interview because he's just on a
massive massive book tour at the moment
and yes I did ask him that question I
did do it uh and we're going to play it
as the cold closed today so trust me you
want to stick around for the whole show
and with all that being said one more
time happy Black History Month to
everybody and let me talk to you about
shaving your balls and then we'll get to
it I've got some breaking news for you
people manscaped now sells beard
products that's right they're once again
revolutionizing Men's Grooming with the
brand new beard hedger Pro kit from a
beard trim to a fresh shave the
technology behind the beard hedger Pro
kit allows you to shape your signature
beard look I feel like the Beard's
looking tight today now you can finally
use manscape products to make your
drapes match your carpet by going to
manscaped.com and using codeave for 20
off and free shipping it's time to tame
your Mane no one likes a weird beard so
say goodbye to all your stubble trouble
with manscape's Pro beard kit my beard
has never looked better once I started
using manscape the pro beard kit starts
with a beer edger which has a waterproof
titanium coated t-blade followed with
beard shampoo conditioner oil and bomb
holy cow they've got everything the pro
beard kit also comes with three free
gifts a beard brush a comb scissors to
ensure your beard is ready to impress so
get 20 off and free shipping with code
Reuben at manscaped.com that's 20 off
with code Reuben at manscape is it
called Reuben or code Dave am I lying
I'm lying to the people
sorry guys I was so focused on this
incredible meme today uh it's code Dave
well there goes the nine eight on the
show Once I make a technical error the
98 is gone nine five is the best we can
do today we shall see I have a good
feeling about it though okay so the the
big news of the last couple days is that
the department of energy has officially
stated that it looks like coronavirus
covid-19 whatever you want to call it at
this point the Wuhan flu that little
cold that you got a while back
that it was leaked from this lab in
Wuhan we also now know when we did a
whole bunch on it yesterday that there
was gain of function research being paid
for by fauci's NIH despite the fact that
under oath he said it was not happening
but it has now even been reported on CNN
that it was happening and gain of
function means basically this is
layman's term stuff that a virus has a
certain type of function and when you
gain the function you you sort of make
it jump so it can do other things say
infect humans so a bat virus that
shouldn't infect humans they do gain of
function research now it's gained the
function to jump and infect humans
remember the video we played yesterday
of Bill Gates saying oh you know there
was this bat virus and then one step
later it suddenly was infecting humans
yeah gain of function which fauci was
funding through NIH through Eco Health
at the Wuhan lab anyway now pretty much
everyone is is basically admitting that
it most likely was a Wuhan lab leak
those of us that are crazy online
creatures who don't believe everything
that the mainstream media tells us we've
been saying that this is a possibility
for a long time I have no doubt like
literally no doubt you can find videos
of mine two years ago at least
entertaining the idea why would I just
swallow this the idea that it wasn't
right like we know that there was some
weird stuff going on there the wet
Market story always sounded weird that
it just came from a bat in a wet Market
the point is if you said that for the
last two years you were either banned or
canceled or Shadow banned or silenced or
shamed by mainstream media they would
call you a conspiracy theory and you're
a fringe lunatic and all of those things
well anyway Stephen Colbert who is a
quote-unquote comedian who took over for
Letterman who was an actual comedian who
does The Late Show over there on CBS he
has been one of the most pro-vax he has
been one of the most Pro Mass one of the
most pro-authoritarian Draconian
lockdown entertainers there is but now
even he is having to admit that this
thing likely came from Wuhan from the
lab and here's him doing comedy I guess
all right there's another surprising
development this weekend uh the
department of energy released a new
report saying a lab leak is the most
likely origin of the covid-19 pandemic
well there it is
Chinese wet markets you're off the hook
wondering why the department of energy
is the one making this judgment is
because that agency oversees a network
of U.S National Laboratories some of
which conduct Advanced biological
research no no
energy Department no bio Labs until you
finish building your electric car
charging stations
stay in your lane they wouldn't release
these findings unless they were
absolutely confident what's that
they made their judgment with low
confidence
yeah you could tell by the way they
delivered the news
um maybe it was a lab like that's stupid
forget I said anything
now it turns out
no matter what the energy Department
says not everyone in the government
agrees to see while the department of
energy suspects it was a lab leak four
other agencies along with the National
Intelligence panel still judge that the
pandemic was likely the result of a
natural transmission and the CIA remains
undecided anyway we'll have more on the
story as soon as anyone has anything
they can prove
you know I really wish we had a sign in
here can we get a sign Daphne on the
computer you can order things can we get
a sign in here that will tell you guys
when to laugh
okay because sometimes I'm looking at
you guys and you aren't laughing at the
good stuff this idiot has a has a sign
they have a huge sign have you guys ever
been to a late night show they have a
giant sign that tells people when to
laugh because otherwise you would not
know when to laugh when listening to
this guy now he's trying to back out of
it at the end but maybe it isn't the you
know the department of energy low
confidence but every single point of
evidence is pointing to it and the fact
is even even if
even if it's somehow turned out not to
be true and who Godly knows if we'll
ever get the the truth right like the
real truthy truth of this thing because
who believes any of the things that
these people tell us at this point
um but even if it turned out not to be
true the fact that he was mocking
everybody along the way well now we have
a fairly important department the
department of energy most people
consider that a top five Department uh
saying that it's uh it's legit
this seems like a problem now I want to
throw back you I'm sure you guys are
gonna remember this clip this is Summer
of 21 okay so this is over a year and a
half ago when Jon Stewart went on
Colbert and mentioned the Wuhan lab leak
now until this very moment no one in
mainstream media would even freaking
touch this thing
um and Jon Stewart went up there and
mentioned it and watch how Colbert watch
how nervous he is while Stewart is just
thrown out a theory you're allowed to
have theories I think this is still
America
what what do you mean by do you mean
like just for perhaps there's a chance
that this was created in a lab there's
an investigation a chance
evidence I'd love to hear that there's a
novel respiratory coronavirus overtaking
Wuhan China what do we do oh you know
who we could ask the Wuhan novel
respiratory coronavirus lab the disease
is the same name as the lab
that's just that's just a little too
weird don't you think and then they ask
those scientists they're like how did
this so wait a minute you work at the
Wuhan respiratory coronavirus lab how
did this happen and they're like a
Pangolin kiss the turtle
[Music]
and you're like no I you you the name of
your life if you look at the name
look at the name can I let me see your
business card show me your business card
oh I work at the
coronavirus lab in Wuhan
wait a second all right John oh my God
oh my God there's been an outbreak of
chocolaty goodness near Hershey
Pennsylvania what do you think happened
like oh I don't know maybe uh steam
shovel mated with a cocoa bean or it's
the Chocolate Factory maybe that's it
that could be
so the reason I'm showing you that and
you guys know I have my issues with Jon
Stewart like he's become ridiculously
woke on the gender stuff and the race
stuff it's it's a damn shame what's
happened to Jon Stewart and it sort of
has led him into his like
quasi-irrelevance right he has this like
I think 10 million dollar a year deal or
something like that with Apple TV for a
show that nobody watches but putting
that aside what was interesting about
that moment is that was the moment where
you were suddenly allowed in mainstream
to talk about it so I'll give John
credit for that he brought the theory
that now appears to be true to the
mainstream a year and a half ago and in
the last year and a half more and more
people started talking about it now
we're getting this uh seeming admission
by the department of energy that it
likely was from the Wuhan lab but what's
interesting about that really is that
Colbert is always giving the machine
what it what it wants and what I mean by
that and I've said this many times but
what I mean by that is there is a series
of people mostly in the media but
politicians too and and probably
institutional leaders and all sorts of
things who never know exactly what
they're talking about or don't really
know what they believe so they always
just say the current thing and by saying
the current thing it keeps them in
cahoots it keeps them in good company
with sort of the elite machine right
you're going to keep your job you're
gonna You're Gonna Get your cash your
you know your your checks are gonna
clear and all of those things but they
are the exact type of people that cause
truth to be on A Time release pill
because they are just giving the machine
what it wants and the Machine doesn't
want truth out there so it kind of just
delays all of the truth that was one of
the things that I described to Bill
Maher uh a couple months back when we
were talking about Stephen Colbert that
crazy that you're right that all the all
the comics that were supposed to put
everybody to bed or whatever it is they
all went bananas left I mean Colby these
guys are terrible like Kimmel to me is
just you may be friends with him
I know a lot of people
yeah like Hughes
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing Colbert yeah he's nothing he's
very successful no no but he's just
giving the machine what it wants all the
time you giving you for my differences
with you I totally respect you it's well
said yeah giving the machine What It
Wants I wish I had thought of that
phraseology that's exactly right so
there's a certain set of people that do
that thing right Bill Maher for all you
know I play Bill Mark lips all the time
right and we've become friendly and I'm
trying to I'm trying to get him there
but he doesn't give the machine what he
wants because he didn't he pushes back
against the woke the guys like Colbert
and Kimmel they're giving it what it
wants all the time they end up being
wrong about everything but they never
get fired and they make a ton of money
and they mock half the country and they
call everyone racists and anti-vaxxers
and conspiracy theorists while
especially in the case of Jimmy Kimmel
uh you know he has been in blackface
many times and his ex-girlfriend Sarah
Silverman has been in blackface many
times and these people really it's it's
their way of of bowing to the thing
don't destroy me because I'm pretty
horrible just I'll do what you want so
that you can give me more money and I
can get my liposuction and whatever else
they do to these freaks anyway as long
as we're talking about Jimmy Kimmel and
we're talking about misinformation and
how they go out of their way to lie and
then the truth becomes delayed here's
Jimmy Kimmel three years ago talking
about how Trump kind of thought that
there was some sort of Wu and lab leak
how nuts it's also pushing U.S
intelligence to find evidence for this
theory that the virus was accidentally
released from a lab in Wuhan that's his
new angle to feed the wing nuts to treat
this virus like it was a conspiracy of
some kind it should have never happened
this plague should never have happened
it could have been stopped
but people chose not to stop it what
people tomorrow he'll blame the Spanish
Flu on Antonio Banderas
uh-huh
we don't have a laugh track in here so I
I didn't know if I was supposed to laugh
or not anyway of course it turns out
that Trump when he was talking about you
know closing the border from China and
that this thing might have been leaked
sort of all the stuff that Jon Stewart
said strange bedfellows Jon Stewart and
Donald Trump turns out that they were
more right than Kimmel uh here's Kimmel
two years ago this is at the height of
covid and this might have of all of the
clips of mainstream media people being
nasty uh really disgusting human beings
with I would say no principles but again
giving the machine what it wants because
the machine wanted everybody vaxed and
obedient I mean this is just this thing
should be I mean
I don't even know what to say about this
thing this this thing should be his on
his Epitaph it's just that bad watch
Dr fauci said that if hospitals get any
more overcrowded they're going to have
to make some very tough choices about
who gets an ICU but out of that choice
doesn't seem so tough to me vaccinated
person having a heart attack yes come
right on him we'll take care of you
unvaccinated guy who gobbled horses goo
rest in peace Wheezy you're
putting aside that it's not funny like
think how vile and now subsequently two
years later factually inaccurate so what
that guy wanted if I
two years ago at 44 years old having not
been vaxed if I had a heart problem or I
was having chest pain he would not have
wanted me to be able to get seen at a
hospital he would have wanted it to go
to somebody else now of course the
ultimate irony of that is that many many
people especially young men are having
incredibly High rates of myocarditis
which is heart issues I've mentioned it
on the show a couple times I know a
young guy 22 years old who was wearing a
heart monitor right now because he got
vacs then boosted did not want to but he
had to do it for college everyone makes
their own choices and he was perfectly
healthy beforehand and is now having
heart issues and this is just one of
that's just one in my personal life but
I know that you probably know somebody
too and we now know all of these stories
so think how vile these people are so
they give the machine what it wants
which okay that would be one thing if it
was just because you want to cash your
check but you're also you're
discriminating against other people
you're othering people you're just doing
the worst of the worst but speaking of
the worst of the worst here's Joe
Scarborough from three years ago calling
Tom Cotton a crazy conspiracy theorist
for that uh
Wuhan labley didn't Tom go to Harvard I
think something tell me so Harvard uh
the guy uh very well educated Tom Cotton
a couple of days ago
uh spouting conspiracy theory to the
Chinese made this virus up in a lab you
have Rush Limbaugh every day
presidential medal freedom of Honor it's
hard to say this is the most Reckless
thing he's ever done but saying that
basically this was just a conspiracy and
this was just made up to hurt Donald
Trump he said something yesterday I
can't even keep up with it but every day
is a new dangerous conspiracy theory I
mean this is this is serious stuff folks
don't worry about your ratings for one
week don't don't try to don't try to
spool up uh some of whoever was wearing
10 10 foil hats in your audience but
that's what's happening
man he is like especially bad I don't
know where they come up with these
people why do they come up with well I
guess I know why like why does corporate
media just get the worst of the worst
like I always say it it's like why if
they would just take bad people just
generally bad journalists generally
people who could just sit there and get
the makeup on and just read the script
but just not be holy horrible but
everything right there that Joe
Scarborough is accusing Tom Cotton of of
is the stuff that he himself is guilty
of of course it is and and for Joe
Scarborough to to tell anyone to not
care about their ratings I'm almost
crying it's so ridiculous but here's
another clown this is msnbc's Nicole
Wallace three years ago and what was she
saying well of course Trump was a
conspiracy theorist related to this lab
leak too it just never ends
traditionally driven by science not
presidential politics and the scientists
aren't the only ones wrangled today by
Trump's effort at reputational repair
the New York Times also advances recent
reporting on U.S intelligence agencies
which we learned this week provided
Intel in the president's pdb as early as
January about the lethal spread of covid
those same agencies now have been tapped
with investigating one of trump world's
most favorite conspiracy theories New
York Times reports this quote senior
Trump Administration officials have
pushed American spy agencies to hunt for
evidence to support an unsubstantiated
theory that a government lab in Wuhan
China was the origin of the coronavirus
outbreak that's according to current and
former American officials man it's wild
guys trust me we had hundreds and
hundreds of Clips to sift through to
show you evidence of this they were
doing this endlessly and now it turns
out to be right and also the way she
says science right you've got to believe
the science but it turns out that Donald
Trump who you didn't think believed in
science was a little more right than you
Nicole Wallace very bad person all right
only one more on this I promise
from the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC here is noted racist and
uh
utterly ridiculous human being Joy read
saying that the lab League Theory had
been debunked three years ago in a lab
in Wuhan China and yet this week Donald
Trump is still pushing the debunked
bunkum despite his own intelligence
community's findings that that is simply
not true on Thursday the intelligence
Community released a rare statement
saying they agree with the scientific
consensus that the virus was not not
man-made but it's not like Trump has a
history of going against the words of
his own intelligence Community or
anything guys the intelligence Community
you know the same intelligence community
that had 51 officials tell us that the
hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation those guys said that
thing and we're supposed to believe them
just terrible and note nobody ever gets
fired nobody ever apologizes great
remember Rachel Maddow with that crazy
rant about you will not get coveted it
cannot affect you get that vaccine you
will be safe you will not transmit it in
the way she does it in that very
emotional way that she speaks and nobody
pays the price for any of this they lie
and lie and lie and that is why so many
people are so broken by by politics and
the media because there is a truth out
there that if you have
there is the truth out there and if you
have your head on roughly straight you
know not to buy all of their nonsense
but they delay it and delay it and delay
it and nobody wants to be canceled and
called a conspiracy theorist and an
anti-vaxxer and the rest of it
um so they just keep going and going and
going and that that is causing the
disconnect the disconnect I would say
between probably your day-to-day life
which is hopefully somewhat functional
and you're doing what you're supposed to
on this planet and then when you watch
these clowns who are protecting the
people in power who were locking people
down and injecting them with crazy
and the list goes on and on anyway what
else do they fear it's not just that
they fear the truth they also fear that
people might come into power who believe
something different than them and they
hate those people so yesterday Joy Reed
and she's freaking out now because as I
mentioned at the top of the show
Governor Ron DeSantis has a new book
coming out today and it's really all
it's called the courage to be free but
it's really about his Florida blueprint
right and I always talk about the
blueprint here I actually started saying
the phrase blueprint because a few
months ago I went to uh his Florida
blueprint education conference but he's
got a blueprint for America when it
comes to education when it comes to
policing when it comes to energy Etc et
cetera et cetera and I'm always talking
about how that blueprint has to be uh
has to be sent out to the rest of the
country so they can look at the
blueprints too hopefully in whatever
sane states are left out there and go by
golly there's some stuff we can do here
by golly there's some stuff we can do
here to to make it better to actually
have Law and Order and have a
functioning economy and have people
moving in instead of moving out and all
those things I didn't even know he was
going to use the blueprint tag in the in
the book when I just started repeating
that phrase anyway Joy Reed's freaking
out because uh as I've been saying for a
long time what they're going to tell you
on DeSantis is that he is Trump but
worse right he is going to be Hitler
with a calculator he's going to be all
of the things Trump was but he's going
to be functional incompetent unlike that
buffoon Trump so he's going to be even
worse I've been telling you this for a
year watch Joy Reed make Dave Rubin look
pretty good story about a cartoon
Creator becoming the voice of the great
white male freakout doesn't end at
Dilbert or even at Elon Musk it ends or
rather begins with white grievance
politics potentially becoming U.S
federal policy if Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis becomes president of the United
States which he is clearly aiming for
America will become the land of total
government control over women's bodies
black history gender identity how you
can teach learn rethink even talk
it would essentially be a more
functionally authoritarian version of
trump a more action less personality
type of President who's basically
offering two options pre-civil rights
America or total control of society
like she should be fired I I don't even
know how else you could say it like
Florida is the freest place in the world
literally in the world there is no one
coming for anybody here you could be gay
here you can be trans here you can be
black you can be white nobody cares we
get 1200 new people a day here actually
are one problem in Florida is that house
prices are high because they simply
cannot build fast enough you know in
places like California where people are
fleeing house prices are still high
because BlackRock and Vanguard are
buying a property left and right that's
a whole other problem which by the way
DeSantis is fighting because he's doing
anti-esg stuff here we have a legit
problem because 1200 people move here a
day they need housing they need
Apartments Etc et cetera uh it's one of
the questions I actually asked you know
obviously I had to sanitizen yesterday
I'm not you guys know like obviously I
like the guy so the interview is mostly
like talking about the good things about
Florida but I said to him I gotta ask
you one tough one and what do we do
about this and he immediately had a
great answer they've had 20 you'll see
more of it later 1 15 Eastern as I said
it'll be on Rumble and YouTube and and I
think it'll be on locals even before
that
um but basically he said that they've
had all these projects you know
governments have projects in the
pipeline those they have a long look go
ahead like a 30-year vision of what they
want to do and he's moving I think I
think he said seven infrastructure
massive infrastructure building projects
uh from 20-year timelines to seven year
timelines so things that will be done in
2030 that shouldn't have been done until
the mid-2040s I mean this is this is
real stuff and it's happening right now
on top of the fact that we're you know
they've cut a lot of Regulation so
things are being built anyway everything
she says there is a lie yes he wants to
go back to pre-civil rights America and
oh it's just it's nuts but what is she
really fearing she's really fearing that
people might start understanding what
freedom is people might start
understanding what America really is all
about and it has nothing to do with the
drivel that she spews every single day
and she's freaking out about this book
because says the book is the blueprint
and there is nothing more that a leftist
fears than information that might free
you
but of course his robust PR team has you
thinking quite the opposite which is why
his new book titled and I'm not making
this up the courage to be free the
courage to be free
as a first-hand account from the blue
collar boy with a dream to take down
Disney and librarians it got scorched by
the New York Times Obviously its
reviewer saying quote all the culture
War Mad Libs can't distract from the
dull coldness at this book's core
and that it will leave some supporters
who have encouraged DeSantis to humanize
himself sorely disappointed the world
DeSantis is building the reviewer said
down in Florida is one that uses the
power of government to make the Dilbert
guys the world feel comfortable they
feel good about themselves Center you
know did you know that this isn't even
baby maga's first book he also penned
dreams from our founding fathers
published in 2011 and it pretty much
sums up what we already know about the
guy David Walt streischer wrote about
the book in the Atlantic saying the most
revealing and consequential element of
the book is the insistence that the role
of slavery and race more broadly does
not seriously change anything about how
we should understand the birth and
development of our country
all right first of all I don't want to
be demonetized today because it would
hurt us in the algorithm I don't really
care about the money but if I say what I
really think about her we're going to
get demonetized then there's no
guacamole for you for lunch so I'm going
to write down three words that I think
sum up uh Joy read quite well
okay
I wrote those two with the words down
I'm going to fold this up okay
and I would like to I will sign this
here I'm going to sign it as well
I'll put it the last day of Black
History Month to
28 23
we're going to send this to a locals
member today someone in the chat who
gives us a good comment and they will
know what I really think of Joy Reed
um yeah Freedom's good lady and you do
need courage to be free and you guys
should get out there and buy the book I
don't I don't get any money for the book
I don't want any money I don't get any
money from the campaign but the guy's
doing the right thing and when you're
doing the right thing you deserve
support so just as simple as that uh and
when she mocks him for going after
Disney and going after a Librarians well
yes we are taking books out of our
elementary schools that teach kids to
give hand jobs it's true regardless of
your feeling of the hand job we
shouldn't be teaching that to children
that's one thing that I think well in
the old days we used to all agree on
even if you you could be the most
pro-hand job person ever but you
shouldn't be teaching it to Children
right like basic stuff here okay and as
far as the Disney thing yeah he's
destroying Disney but what is he doing
he is not destroying Disney out of spite
and taking away rights from them he's
taking away their special exemption
status their special governing status
which officially ends well it officially
ended yesterday so today is their first
full day of work without their special
governing status what is Mickey Mouse
going to do here's the Santa's talking
about just that how do you give one
theme park its own government and then
treat all the other theme parks
differently and so we believe that that
that was not good policy We Believe
being joined at the hip with this one
california-based company was not
something that was justifiable or
sustainable and so we said we're going
to do something about it and so now
we're basically Disney's going to be
treated like Sea World is treated or
like any of these others and that's
really uh the the fair thing to do so
I'll be signing the bill momentarily and
that will officially end the
self-governing status here in Central
Florida for Disney
[Applause]
so what's fascinating about this and I
know you guys know this but Joy Reid
does not like Freedom she actually
doesn't like fairness and she really
doesn't like equality she likes Equity
what DeSantis is doing is just making
things more fair and more equal and
taking away special tax rights taking
away this self-governing policy and all
of those things so now Disney will be
treated like Sea World should Sea World
be allowed to basically have its own
government as well after everything
they've done to Shamu obviously not
obviously not so he's doing the free
thing but freedom is the word they hate
the most which is why every time they
even say the word Freedom there's
there's this glimmer in their eye they
resent Freedom they resent your ability
to think for yourself because once you
think for yourself well first off you
don't need to watch a clown like that
but then you would realize that all of
her policies are ridiculous and point
being since when was the Left
pro-corporation Right wasn't the left
the way we've always known the left to
be they hated evil corporations Bernie
Sanders who does he hate more than
people that do things nothing but no
Bernie he hates corporate I hate
corporations
he hates corporations but for some
reason she loves corporations she loves
giant corporations that have special
benefits because leftists actually don't
believe in anything but power that
really is the truth and here is DeSantis
side and the bill so uh I'm gonna put my
John Hancock on this piece of
legislation that'll that'll make it
official and so just look at your watch
and you'll know at what time the
corporate Kingdom finally came to an end
[Applause]
all right today is the 27th yes
I have a book coming on the 28th of
course I should know what day it is
all right
well
[Applause]
you know it's interesting I mentioned
the thing about how leftists were
supposed to hate corporations but
Phoenix just said to me as that video
was playing that Republicans in the 90s
would have hated this right like so
Republicans of the 90s would have hated
the idea that the government is going
after a corporation even if that
Corporation had special uh Authority
right but that shows you things are
changing when corporations decide to go
after our kids the Republicans of 2023
at least here in the Free State of
Florida have had enough and are going to
actually do something about it it's
quite beautiful but at a cultural level
why did he do this he did this because
of we've shown you many of those videos
all of the employees at the Dei the
diversity equity and inclusion
departments at Disney talking about how
they literally are putting uh propaganda
into the programming how they are
putting critical race Theory into
cartoons and all of the gender queer
nonsense and everything else they refuse
to let kids be kids right and they want
to indoctrinate these children and they
literally tell you that on video tape
they tell you that and what happens when
that happens well then it starts leaking
all over Society so this is a probably a
lesser known story to some of you guys
but this is absolutely wild Roald Dahl
and he was the uh the original well he's
a he's a writer was a writer uh for who
wrote probably dozens of books right
dozens if not hundreds of books
children's books mostly uh who wrote
Willy Wonka most famously eventually the
estate sold his publishing rights and
now the company that bought the
publishing rights art is going in and
changing to make things more politically
correct uh some of the original works of
doll it's rather extraordinary so
Samantha Smith had this tweet up here it
says Roald Dahl's Publishers have made
hundreds of changes to his books
claiming the language used was offensive
if you think this sounds like something
straight out of 1984 it's because it is
uh and there's a couple a couple things
here um am I gonna be able to read that
on there I don't know that I can quite
see that on there do I have that at my
notes can you guys see it there oh I do
have it on my notes give me one second
guys I'm folding up papers over here
uh so look at this I'll just read the
first one and then you can go back and
read the other ones yourself in the
original The Witches the lion red don't
be foolish my grandmother said you can't
go around pulling the hair of every lady
you meet even if she is wearing gloves
just you try it and see what happens
that was in the 2001 edition of The
Witches uh in the 2022 Edition it's been
changed don't be foolish my grandmother
said besides there are plenty of other
reasons why women might wear wigs and
there are certainly and there is
certainly nothing wrong with that I'll
just give you one more in the middle uh
also from oh you know I'll give you the
bottom one from Matilda which was a
great movie by the way great kids movie
she went
she went on olden day sailing ships with
Joseph Conrad she went to Africa with
Ernest Hemingway and to India with
rouyard Kipling and here's the new one
she went to 19th century Estates with
Jane Austen she went to Africa with
Ernest Hemingway and California with
John Steinbeck the point is whether you
think that these changes are cataclysmic
or not this is how art changes this is
how we we put our Val not our values but
the the values
of a really rotten Society on works of
the past that actually were pieces of
Art and if all of this if Matilda and
the witches don't affect you well yes I
said he wrote Willy Wonka this is wild
remember Augustus Gloop remember the fat
German child who fell in the river of
chocolate got stuck
in that pipe right very sad story okay I
think he ended up in the mushroom not
the mushroom room the marshmallow room
horrible okay Augustus Gloop they are no
longer going to call him fat instead he
will be described as give me it what is
it here he's going to be described as
enormous he will not be fat according to
the telegraph uh oh and the Oompa
Loompas are no longer small men they're
small people because we wouldn't want to
offend a female Oompa Loompa not that
anyone knows what a female is and to the
point of all of this as you guys know
that the wonderful I would say prophetic
what was once a work of fiction but
unfortunately has become reality George
Orwell's 1984 I thought this quote was
just perfect because this just this is
exactly what's happening in front of our
eyes this is this is the most famous
quote from 1984 of course every record
has been destroyed or falsified every
book Rewritten every picture has been
repainted every statue and Street
building has been renamed every date has
been altered and the process is
continuing day by day and minute by
minute history has stopped nothing
exists except an endless present in
which the party is always right I mean
my God does it get more prophetic than
that
not really but
if you want the completely wrong take on
everything I just described here's Ana
Navarro from The View
what else happens is
um I think overreaching and over
compensating and just overdoing it
because to me when you are removing all
gender-specific words from the Oompa
Loompas I mean people the Oompa Loompas
are fictional yeah they're made believed
but you know when you're doing that kind
of thing it then it lends itself for
folks uh on the right to say oh this is
what Walt Disney is all about you've got
to be anti-work let's pass an anti-world
act let me tell you what I'm concerned
about I'm not concerned about you
editing out words from a book I think
that's stupid I'm concerned about you
editing out black history studies from
AP courses in Florida and I you know I
Michael
Anna
I'm gonna do it again I'm gonna write
down three words that I think about Anna
Navarro
I'm going to fold it up
you can sign it
to
28 23 we will send this somebody after
the show
Anna okay she almost got it right there
she almost got it right that the woke
overreach with everything so we
shouldn't be concerned about so they're
doing too much by caring about Oompa
loompa's gender and sexuality and the
rest of it who would have thought in
2023 we'd be talking about Oompa
loompa's gender the who are incredible
people and the fact that so many of them
escaped the snozz wangers and that whole
thing we don't have to get into that
right now but the point guys is that
then of course what does she do
it's not about the people who are
changing the work and changing the
meaning of words and confusing everybody
and putting the standards of 2023 on
works of the past what is it really
about it's about what's happening here
in Florida of which she completely Lies
We are not not teaching African-American
history it was one course that they
wanted to teach critical race Theory and
gender queer Theory and push for
reparations and a whole bunch more so
that a high school student learning that
would get college credit and
desantisette is enough she knows she's
lying everyone at that table knows she's
lying the producer knows she's lying and
everyone at ABC knows she's lying much
like Andrea Mitchell lied about this and
we played that clip last week and then
she gave that half-assed apology so at
some point you just have to know that
their job is to lie their job is to push
misinformation their job actually is to
do everything from that quote in 1984
that I just read to you and what is this
do and now here's the silver line and
guys and trust me it's a good one the
Silver Lining is that when these people
go more hysterical and they believe in
censorship and they believe in lies and
they believe in all the authoritarian
policies that you can possibly imagine
what it does is it takes good people
decent people maybe who aren't
completely driven by politics who
believe in other things who enjoy life
whatever that means to them and it
creates very strange bedfellows in
people so I am very proud of the clip
that I am about to show you here because
when I was on Bill Marshall about seven
eight months ago I said to him you gotta
have Gutfeld on the show because I think
you guys first off you're both late
night comedians now Gutfeld is now
number one at late night gutfeld's a
great dude obviously bill and I hit it
off despite the differences I said you
gotta have him on he said I'll think
about it I'll think about it and then
about two months later I got a call from
Bill's producer and he said hey can you
connect us with Gutfeld well Gutfeld was
on Bill Maher's podcast on Sunday and
here they are remember one is on Fox
News Right conservative scary Fox News
and one is liberal Bill Maher here they
are getting stoned and drunk talking
about the brutal effects of cancel
culture and you couldn't make it because
like he says they are a word a million
times yeah that kind of stuff we're like
in kindergarten now where we have to say
pee pee and poo poo and r word well
Animal House I think Animal House still
holds up but you can you could not do
that movie especially in the in the
nightclub scene
oh what did you do you mind if you we
dance with your dates that whole thing
would never happen it would never happen
that's the first time I ever saw but
it's every month it's every movie yeah
it's every I mean any movie made even 10
years ago
and there's something there that you you
if you really examine who you are you
probably are not offended at all we all
laughed at this stuff and it wasn't
terribly we know what something's
terribly offensive but when you hear it
now in 2023
you
hunch up because you know not because it
itself but because you know the reaction
will cause yes as trust me that's the
Silver Lining because that's how we beat
this thing we maybe don't beat it fully
by politics there are moments we can and
DeSantis is doing that whole blueprint
thing and all that that's just fine but
we beat it with these strange alliances
right we beat it by by Myanmar being
able to do our thing by Gutfeld and Mar
being able to do their thing whatever
you're doing in your life to bridge
those gaps and if all of the same people
keep doing that the machine will get
crazier and crazier it'll always ramp up
the crazy right Joy Reed has no way to
get out of the of the bottomless pitch
he has put herself into uh Chuck
Scarborough can't get out the machine
will keep going they're all in on it too
deep they they have pushed it too far so
they cannot come back which is the damn
shame because for the years that all of
us were warning them guys can you just
not lie about everything could you just
not be so completely evil you can be
mostly evil but not completely but they
couldn't listen so what they are going
to do is and this is my hope and I
believe it can happen in 2024 at a
political level but it will first take
the it will take the personal and
cultural level first
we can have the most incredible Alliance
forming right now of those ex-libs and
the Libertarians and the conservatives
and the religious people and we can put
together something under the banner of
freedom
if you believe in Freedom and you
believe this country is good
we gotta we got a shot we got a chance
and we gotta team up and do it and I
think that's happening right now uh to
that point why this all comes around at
a cultural level which is why I thought
that was interesting I mean again you
got the number one host in late night
and who's on the conservative Fox News
and the biggest lib
even though the left hates him now the
biggest lib on television in billimar uh
but there's this other guy this guy
Aiden Ross uh and if you don't know him
he is the number one streamer on Twitch
which is a video game platform which has
crazy following and he's the number one
guy in there I mean this guy gets
bananas who even estimate how many views
he gets a day probably like 50 million
views a day like something just
completely completely insane he's a huge
influencer uh and he just tweeted
something very controversial had the
internet lit on fire my God in all caps
he said there are only two genders now
I'm not a I'm not a twitch guy okay I'm
not I'm not a video game guy to any
extent anymore I'm trying to get back in
on it Conor's trying to give me a little
video game 101 situation over here I can
still do Mario Brothers 8-bit Nintendo
uh you know if you warp to four and warp
to eight and you don't lose you don't
die once uh you can beat that game in
about 12 minutes my buddy Mike Sherman
did it in college
um this kid gets about 60 this is per
month oh from the tweet alone from that
tweet alone just to show you the
influence that this kid has 61 million
views about 525 000 likes about 70 000
retweets 31 000 comments all he did was
say something that we all knew was true
we all knew it
a couple years ago we all knew it was
true but now it's controversial and now
of course there's people trying to
cancel them and get his deals cut and
everything else but the point is whether
it is some random video game kid or it's
the number one host in late night or
it's me or it's you we can start putting
the pieces together here we've got the
blueprint people and on that note we're
going to cold close you today with a
preview of my interview with Governor
DeSantis because yes I did ask him the
question okay I did ask him the question
the full thing will be up at 1 15
Eastern on YouTube Rumble and on locals
all at the same time so check out this
cold close this is this is the debut of
this thing across across the board uh
and then we got a post game show for you
in about 46 seconds well the clip's
probably about a 50 seconds so give me
let's give me uh 64 seconds how about
that and we'll see in just a little bit
okay I got one more for you I know
you're on a massive Blitz and you got to
get to number one in New York Times
although the ultimate credit would be if
they don't put you on at all because
then you can really stick it to them of
course but is there any other sort of
announcement you might want to make or
anything else you might want to talk
about as long as we're just chatting
here you know anything else you want to
say about anything or we could just end
this now you tell me wouldn't you like
to know I mean that'd be that'd be a
good one for you but uh
[Music]
thank you